so what's kind of interesting at present
is that it looks so we might be in a
phase of normal science where business
as usual is gonna make a whole lot of
progress you know assuming the computer
industry can keep producing better
hardware and keep doing computations
burning less energy so they can keep
doing that with Moore's law for another
ten years or twenty years I think
business as usual is gonna take us a
huge way obviously if we get big
breakthroughs because sexual
breakthroughs that'll take us further I
think one of the big breakthroughs is
going to come is we're going to
understand the brain this is just a bet
my personal belief is we're gonna get
close enough to how the brain really
does do these things that suddenly it
all begins to click and we kind of fall
into a minimum where it's just obvious
how the brain is actually doing this
stuff and I think there might be quite
close to that and that would be another
revolution because that would affect all
sorts of things like education and our
sense of who we are that would be very
exciting I'm hoping I get to see that